good morning Millennials I decided I
wanted to new a new intro and I think I
found it yesterday ready okay morning
Millennials hey hey hey hey let me know
what you guys think about that you
podcasters can't hear but you're missing
out on so much already it's I I think
that could work and double has a great
leg exercise for you oh I mean my knees
are broken and I'm gonna need to go to
the hospital after this so as long as
you just take me there I'll be good but
if you did that once a day you would
have sighs of Steel I mean actually do
have thighs it's still just not in the
way that I want you know also I can't
believe it's only Wednesday because the
past two days have been so hard for me
just physically like on my face I think
today like Wednesday it's like I finally
got my face together from Sunday do you
know what I mean yeah it's like I got a
new sweater yes from from revolve
Tularosa Wow yes I'm so Danielle
Bernstein and I got the same shoes I
always wear I didn't realize I was
co-hosting with Olivia culpo today right
that's the thing about being an
influencer you never know who's gonna
show up and I also like flat ironed my
front pieces like I feel good except now
I'm looking at the feed and I want to
die but it's fine because I feel
empowered we actually kind of matched
today I said that to you when you walked
in but you were like so involved in your
lips you said Matt I said I thought oh I
thought you were saying that I was
mansion as chic as my shoes match my bag
with trench my earmuffs which match my
sweaters do you think I look at that
much detail and your whole look but it's
dark over there I thought maybe you had
no I'm sorry and I've got a Gucci bear
Gucci bear Gucci bear did you ever get
you better teach Americans very few bear
I left him he reminds me a CEO you know
I do love a bell sleeve like but I can't
tell you how [ __ ] annoying they are
Kristen Bell sleeve yes I wore this to
dinner last night with Margaux and
literally as a sushi restaurant yeah I
tried went to dinner you and hear the
craziest thing you took her to sushi
Sachi and then who knows oh wait what
are you gonna say live roaches what you
didn't see in the toasters in the New
York scenes actually someone posted a
screenshot of a review of sushi sake
that they of live regions which location
I don't know believes they didn't want
to know I walked into sushi Sachi and
Ben calls me and he goes I don't want
you to freak out and like when your
husband calls you I'm like oh my god not
even yeah like the worst he goes but so
many people are DMing
and I'm like oh my god what did I post
like you know I accidentally I'm like a
[ __ ] he's like don't freak out but like
SEC he got a C and I was like I'll it
like okay that's information I should
have known but in the reals and I'm like
you're not you don't no longer have the
privilege to call me because you're
insane like I always think the worst and
when he phrases things like that like I
don't want you to freak out what do you
think I think terrorist attack right my
whole family's dead so now okay because
piecing it together they got a seed
because there's AI Verge's know did they
see in which location its employment
sure if we go and investigate
obviously it's obviously the Upper East
Side run because that it's like the
scariest so I feel like it would be the
Chelsea wine Chelsea has roaches but the
Chelsea one is much newer and clearer
and bigger I don't know Chelsea is more
rosy vibes like Upper East Side their
neighbors wouldn't wouldn't stand for
that well you know what everywhere the
meals list is [ __ ] amazing roaches
and all but these Slim's like we're
dipping into everything it's so annoying
but wait so we're going when I when I
live with what I hang out with Mario
like I'm her father like I just pay for
stuff right now I'm her husband I just
like she doesn't even pull out her
wallet like she just lives in such a
nice life and last night we like really
feasted like appetizers entrees and like
the place is already like kind of
expensive for sushi but like when you
eat like kings it's even more - yeah
died cokes like refill oh man do I never
see BK for lunch that's I just thought
if I would love that
okay let's we'll handle it afterwards
and so I go to pay the check and I don't
have my wallet and I'm like holy [ __ ]
I'm like okay I'm Apple pay or whatever
they didn't have that I'm like usually
when I don't have my wallet I don't
figure out immediately because there's
so many things I'm like I have cash I'll
write a check like no Ben mo yeah and
then I'm like okay Margo you have a
wallet like let me just quick pay you
the money and you put it on your debit
card Margo just debit card got frauded
yeah so we were at this [ __ ]
restaurant with no money and I honestly
like freaked out marks like wait I have
some cash I'm like [ __ ] here three
dollars ain't gonna help homegirl pulls
out a wad of cash
she's like 24 just like here's 100 it
was 130 I was like look you noticed and
Margo having 130 dollars on her it's
like me having $100,000 in cash on me
yeah I was like she's rich and because
she didn't have any money on her mom
gave her cash like to live oh right and
it's just for situation yes like this
and I
given Margolick an emergency $30 because
she's like never walks around with money
and I think it's so dangerous so a while
ago I had given her emergency like forty
somebody tipped into that emergency and
we ended up literally with like 150
which is the bill was 130
it was literally a miracle on the Hudson
Wow and now I owe Margo I'm like thanks
for dinner god forbid she picks it up
she said no you have to pay me back
she said I don't have to give her back
the emergency 20 because it's so
dangerous to not walk around with any
money yet like what if you need a cab
ever since I went to Vegas with TV geez
your phone ever since I went to Vegas
with TPG I check out so much money once
I'm lost some I still have that wad of
cash my wallet and it feels so
empowering to walk around with money it
does and they'll feel like you're a
target you can like tip in cash with a
nail place and you know that it's going
directly to them instead of someone's
pocket if you read the New York Times
art that article really blew up
Manhattan yeah it really the worst
everyone wants to think oh not my nail
salons but yes your nail salon except I
went to a nail salon when I was at NYU
like downtown and in the bathroom there
was a sign it was like please don't read
the New York Times article it's not
about all all of us that's why someone
put that up who it's about if you guys
don't know in when we were in high
school
no no this was recently this was maybe
three years ago Jackie oh yeah I was if
you just said that you were in college
yeah you said you were downtown at MIT
okay sure whatever there was a huge
expose written on the New York Times
about all like the little Korean now
places and how it's like a terrible like
hierarchy where the girls live in bunk
beds with like 15 people and all the
tips go to the owner and it's just like
so terrible they're so mean to them and
then they wear all these name tags that
are not in their names I like Kimmy
Schmidt right by the way why is it
Netflix promoting Kimmy Schmidt
something so weird happen there
something so weird there - season was
split in two must be like the director
like I mean the director is Tina Fey but
I'm sure there's someone in there higher
up who's like an assaulter and
something's coming out oh my god no
either way you know that when we okay
when we used to work at oath there was
um another woman there and she was on
Yahoo Finance and she was like a Big
Time magazine editor and her husband was
Kimmy Schmidt creator but it's
definitely Mike a nice couple he was
really nice he is so sweet and she was I
was getting her hair done and like she
was so nice but I always wanted to like
audition for her you know for a role you
know I can you know
I took be kidding like if if Kimmy broke
her foot during ishm it live I couldn't
figure understand you're such a diverse
character that like you can go from
paying kimmy schmitt to compose well
right but the I'm diverse but I have to
have red hair why do they named all
red-headed actresses with the name Kimmy
I don't know
Kim plus I had to business I mean had
many business call yesterday but I'm
both of them I ended it with like
they're like reach they're like email me
if you need anything and I said yeah
call me beat me if you want to reach me
but I was like older gentleman they were
like oh sure yeah I'm they're like what
you think I've a pager like you have a
beaver - nobody understood it I'm sorry
also someone didn't mention that your
sweater is a modified updated version of
the period sweater hmm okay well the
colors are picking it up to be on the
camera like a little bit more pinky red
it's more like Browns and no its period
for sure yeah try as I made to deny its
period very fine with that
also so I've been I told you about my
trip to Mexico yes I know you're so
excited you leave tomorrow I'll leave
tomorrow scheduling update again just in
case you missed it tomorrow will be a
podcast only episode could be something
very exciting yeah like a really good
juicy guest or it just could be a
regular person yeah we don't get your
hopes up we're always like saying stuff
and they're not doing it but if it
doesn't happen we'll tell you what it
was supposed to be oh yeah because we're
nice yeah it's not like top secret or
anything it's not a secret project
Fridays if it was we'd have to tell
everyone that it was a secret project
right Friday we have counselors snitch
here to counsel all of us on the toast
mm-hm and Monday Darren Carr pre having
an e-coat unless I'm FOMO about Darren
carpet out so much snitch but but I feel
like it's actually great for you because
you'll just watch it like you would
watch it and you are a consumer of that
when I'm not here I don't watch because
I found it infuriating like a someone's
in my seat like totally farting and be
like when Ben's on I just take such
umbrage with all the lies he tells about
me but when Darren's on I do watch cuz
it's important if it's informative wellö
sanity yesterday I was saying her like
finally for the first time in my life
like I'm packing for a trip and I'm
[ __ ] prepared and I have to say it's
really hurt to shop for shoes the
wedding is like all outside so like as
much as I want to wear stilettos like
there's grass there's sand so I needed
that good sensible chunky heel options
and I started shopping at JustFab have
you ever shopped no not yet okay now I'm
a member just raving about it I don't
even didn't even know they had
memberships like monthly
and it's honestly it's so worth it it's
like so house for shoes exactly except
it's not pretentious okay no and I
seriously am a VIP member for JustFab
and I'm really enjoying it you know I'm
a very important prostitute okay so now
is really the time for you to sign up
for VIP membership because you'll get
your first JustFab style for as low as
ten dollars go to Jeff's fab comm slash
toast now to get this exclusive VIP
offer that's just fab fab that's sorry I
apparently am like Long Island trash
that's just fab.com slash toast get your
first tile for just ten dollars honestly
the thing about it it's like the shoes
are just so reasonably price you think
they're gonna come and like be made out
of paper but they're not like it's legit
Wow make safety I'm excited say it
sounds like your wardrobe is really
evolving at a rebirth for this trip and
I'm excited to see I hope you take some
premium content oh my god what I need
you to get a message through to your
husband oh god what take better pictures
his [ __ ] is terrible the Monto his those
videos and he posts on his big staff so
blurry who wants to watch that he and
like he really is all about like the
message he's like it doesn't matter but
it looks like it's all about the message
I'm like dude no it's not he takes the
worst photos like I've never not one
picture on my Instagram has ever been
taken by them it's not even the photos
like I wish we'd just be photos like
when he posts a video of his steak bone
so shaky and is a tremor tremor take a
picture with this tape oh yes just it's
I just wish you would tell them that and
honestly you could take a page out of
his son's book because he's shown him
showing him up every day how was it been
working being a stage mom for Theo in
the past couple of weeks it's been
incredible because not only like are the
people enjoying it but it really every
day I'm forced to stare at pictures of
Theo on my phone and make them
perfection and it feels like now
obviously it's not the same effect is
when I'm with him and he's starting in
my face and it's beautiful oh my god
but it's like I really I get to stare at
his face for more hours in the day than
I would have if I wasn't generating
pretty man Connor have you ever actually
heard feel fart no of course not no he's
always styling but yesterday I heard a
little sound like Theo did you fart like
as a joke and then I choked and I was
like oh you did oh yeah his farts are
definitely
yeah so I'm planning on taking so much
premium content in Mexico because like
it's gonna be beautiful and also my
outfits are just so supreme but I'm
stuffed with literally the worst
photographer in America and Mexico and
the problem with him is he's so tall and
people think oh it's better firm at high
angle like this isn't my space no though
he's Ben's defense I did train him that
way when I was morbidly obese because
that's the only regular look you'd
rather look super short than super fat
but now I'm like you know I'm kind of
snatched so you know you can bring it
down a couple inches and it's just like
straight I always like I give the phone
to Zach like straight on and then
sometimes I make him get down on the
floor and like maybe Ben would like hear
this and feel you know like he wants to
make a change in his life but he doesn't
watch the toes cuz he's not supportive
no I'm kidding he has a real life and
he's not supportive never supporting me
in my endeavors
oh speaking of my endeavors 12 o'clock
today Eastern Time we have two
California shows second Houston show and
second Greensville Greenville South
Carolina show being released for presale
on patreon I'm not gonna lie I do have a
feeling some of those shows might sell
out in presale and honestly I'm sorry
but if you wanna just become a patreon
member for the month I would suggest
doing that now on patreon.com slash
morning trust because that's where
presale is gonna be good problem to have
sis Oh totally by the way watch how like
novice to my shows that I was gonna say
none of them are gonna sell out I'm just
gonna be like that tomorrow morning like
so yeah they're still thinking about
that girl who ate her words that's me
and everything else okay are you ready
for the Fast Five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast I guess I
guess there are some there are some
heavy-hitting stories the first story I
want to say welcome to all of our
viewers in the Midwest who are watching
live because they don't have work today
because of the polar vortex oh my god
Ben was telling you about this like you
die if you go outside quote coldest air
in a generation hits the Midwest
officials warm warned not warn you with
shorty and foot it is not warm of almost
instant frostbite even for the hardiest
cold tested Americans the deep freeze
sweeping over the Midwest will be brutal
officials warned of almost instant
frostbite as temperatures in the region
plunged below zero Wednesday some state
offices are closed and postal workers
won't deliver mail in
States thousands of flights have been
canceled along with dozens of train
services most of them in and out of
Chicago about two hundred and twelve
million people or 72% of the continental
US population will see temperatures drop
below freezing over the next few days
and more than 83 million Americans about
25 percent of the US population will
suffer sub-zero temperatures at some
point between Wednesday and Monday with
at least five deaths linked to the
extreme conditions this week authorities
are urging people to bundle up stay
inside and check up on the elderly and
vulnerable and what experts are
describing as the coldest air in a
generation well like honestly I feel
like I almost don't adhering about this
yesterday people needed more notice like
to go to the grocery store and stock up
on canned goods and blankets I heard
that this a few days ago uh so yeah it's
just you can't leave your house and you
can't go to work some of the twisters so
we're watching live to say it's negative
49 here and then with the windchill
factor in some places it makes it colder
right
what even is that it's so crazy I think
the lowest temperature I've ever like
been around is like under 10 I never
been on the negative I remember one time
seeing like below 17 when I was that
Colgate oh yeah upstate it's cold it's
freezing in Minnesota frostbite can hit
in minutes look at this student holy
[ __ ] he's got frost it looks like he has
for us what's first bite is that just
like when you're like what is it
frostbite is caused by the freezing of
the skin and underlying tissues it's the
most common on the fingers toes nose
ears cheeks and chin severe cases can
kill body tissue whoo and then you have
like you know be treated no you lose
feeling I think that's what happened to
um Walt Disney no he was just frozen
cryogenically frozen its what how many
silver beads oh yeah but his foot was
bug I think cuz of the frostbite unclear
but I'll have to watch the movie and get
back to you yeah unclear honestly what's
so crazy is that today's a beautiful day
out here in New York right and then I
was seeing that the polar vortex is
gonna invert in some way and in some
places we'll see 70 degrees by this
weekend
what's our weekend looking like let's
take a look it's well I'm gonna be in
sunny Mexico okay for us oh now drinking
a margarita and the sombrero 24 36 48 20
to 48 what sounds like my locker
combination totally I went in to
SoulCycle I literally never stopped
talking about it cuz like I'm just one
of those girls now and I made my
77077 yes and when I left to go to class
I left it open and all I lost was my
[ __ ] chapstick which was really
devastating actually do you have a
recommendation for those under eye
patches to put on your may face but for
a year like while you're doing your eye
makeup oh I don't do them while I'm
doing my eye makeup I feel like those
ones are just they're not even like they
don't have product and then it's just to
catch the to catch the eye shut for the
world but um no I don't use those
because if I if I get droppage I just
brush it off and then I do my concealer
me true so but I love under eye patches
that like hydrate yeah okay Thomas Roth
or no Laszlo's are the best ones
oh really put them in the fridge is what
skinny confidential told me I mean
really just is a shock to the system
it's like putting cucumbers over your
eyes I love shocking my system I love
and I got so many free ones like a year
ago at a gifting suite um and I think
I'm like down to my last two play we
either have to like go now buy them or
like me thirsty to the publicist which
honestly is so worth it I was thirsty to
the tart publicist a long time ago and
now she knows my order like every couple
months I'll get my salt life by tart
like a couple brushes and oh and my
shape tape nice thirst goes a long way
just ass Priyanka Chopra right well I
hope all of our Midwest toasters are
staying toasty stay inside do not be
brave do not go outside to stay inside
watch oh yeah join patreon oh my god
take your dogs inside people are so
annoying like I was eating their dogs in
their backyards like in their little dog
houses bring them inside okay hold up
vortex
it's an Amy Poehler vortex it's a north
polar vote at okay I'm done um and yeah
welcome to watching live what do you
think yeah join us grab a seat tell
friends and you're super bored and
looking for extra premium content
Patriots does Tim say you two more
episodes coming out there bow me super
juicy I just got like we're doing a home
tour with Olivia I'm excited because
I've only been to her apartment once and
I'm excited for her to give me the tour
can i film that $1 yeah great you got to
um I haven't been to her apartment since
all of her furniture came I women they
have like all of Zach's ugly man
furniture and it still looks good yeah
no it's definitely a man furniture but
it was get out rid of it they they block
all the furniture from his old apartment
like brown wooden stuff he all have the
same couch fun
oh my god it's like actually important
yeah we like everyone to like throw me
an extra seat that I could put in
between the cushions do you need one
could something about getting rid of my
one extra see it I don't need it but
your couch is so big that it makes me
want mine to be big I think my couch is
too big and I'm thinking about getting
on the head with you so I think it's
perfectly sized for Theo well I'm just
thinking about it
okay let me know this next story is so
sad and gives me the largest pit and
pain in my stomach empire star Jessie
smell it victim of possible racist and
homophobic attack empire star Jesse
smell it says he was attacked in Chicago
by two brutes who spewed racist and
homophobic slurs at him doused him with
a quote chemical substance and tied a
rope around his neck please said quote
the Chicago Police Department received a
report of a possible racially charged
assault and battery involving a cast
member of the television show Empire the
department said in the statement quote
given the severity of the allegations we
are taking this investigation very
seriously and treating it as a possible
hate crime the openly gay hauteur of all
of his photos the openly gay 35 year old
Smollett who plays singer-songwriter
Jamal Lyon on the hit Fox series was
walking in the city early Tuesday
morning when quote to unknown offenders
approached him and gained his attention
by yelling out racial and homophobic
slurs towards him according to the
police they then quote began to batter
the victim with their hands about their
the face and poured an unknown chemical
substance on the victim
while one of the offenders wrapped a
rope around his neck before both fled
the scene cop said police said smell it
took himself to a hospital where he was
in quote good condition and a source
told the post he was released later
Tuesday TMZ citing quote sources
directly connected to Jesse alleged the
assailants also yelled this is Magga
country during the assault but a Chicago
police spokeswoman told the post cops
don't have confirmation on that yet okay
legit this is the worst story ever Holt
was heard this is like a story you would
hear about like happening like 20 years
ago like when the gay bashing was like
really popular and they would look look
or bleach down people's throat and they
left that guy like tied up to a fence
and he died remember that yeah i'ma feel
like honestly this is the worst story I
ever heard and when I heard it like I
wanted to die no it's it's so horrible
and I hope they catch these [ __ ]
like did these [ __ ] just walk around
with rope and bleacher like they they
saw him out you know
it's unclear but TMZ also noted that the
attack comes eight days after a letter
was sent to him
young guy studios with cutout letters
reading you will die black not my words
[ __ ]
TMZ also reported alongside photos of
the vial note so do they think it's
related it could be they're probably
investigating that that is so crazy it's
really so sad but to be like so brutally
uh beat up but then released the next
day hopefully he's okay yeah but like
chemicals like I think I had read
somewhere it was bleach but that's not
confirmed but like that's how you kill
someone right bleach down the throat and
the rope around the neck nuts
Psychopaths literally I hope they burn
in hell and a twenty five night we
should like they find them and it's an
eye for an eye you know hey I know we
don't operate like that but we really
should sometimes I just get creative
yeah but it's like they're just gonna go
to prison for a couple years then they
like be out doing it again no but
hopefully they go to prison with people
and they know and they hear this story
because sometimes those prisoners can
there is a hierarchy justice yeah but I
don't think like prison like they really
uh the hierarchy goes like if you molest
a child like you're the worst you know I
don't know this is pretty [ __ ] mad no
it's so [ __ ] crazy and honestly
sometimes a justice system like doesn't
do justice and I just feel like no
matter what happens sometimes justice
isn't enough this is not enough no and
it hasn't even it justice hasn't even
been served yet I don't think they found
the guys no I mean it also just happened
yesterday but oh and you know it was
like so sad about the whole thing he was
out late at night going to Subway to get
a sandwich like that's something I would
you can't even get a sandwich in peace
totally it's like not that to make it
about made but you know I'm feeling less
and less like safe walking around like
at night now alone yeah even though it's
happened in Chicago and labor he has
nothing to do with me I'm just saying we
live in a terrible world we really do
and this like just couldn't firms it
it's I balloons this event occurred in
Pittsville USA yes
population those two [ __ ] yeah
uh well anyways we're thinking of him
and I wish him a speedy recovery and
[ __ ] justice or wealth awash Lima in
whatever form it decides to take yeah
you know some of us I think we just
gotta get together and kill those guys
I'm not inciting violence though when we
were at Earth I got in trouble for
saying I wanted to step on the neck of
oh the man who
the Manchester bombing and you wanted to
step on his I want to step on a sack and
kill him with my own bare hands and I
got in trouble from legal saying I was
inciting violence oh you did yeah that's
why we had that whole sensitivity
trainer sensitivity training because of
Dan tonight yeah Wow boy am I glad to be
out of there yeah okay so now I'll say
it again I would like to step on the
throats of these people I want to watch
okay next story is more lighthearted
than funny also sad for Ariana Grande oh
you misspelled her seven rings tattoo
everyone makes mistakes but fans notice
ariana grande made a more permanent
blunder after she revealed her latest
tattoo on Tuesday the singer got the new
ink on the palm of her hand while it was
supposed to spell out seven rings in
Japanese fans noticed Grande's design
actually translated to she cheerin which
is a small charcoal grill and it's the
one that they use at Korean barbecues
like that little will you put like the
little raw steak on it luckily she
didn't seem too bothered by the error
indeed I left out the symbol which I've
got which should have gone in between
she wrote in a sense deleted tweest it
hurt like [ __ ] still looks tight
I wouldn't have lasted one her symbol
lmao but this spot also peels a ton and
won't last so if I miss it enough I'll
suffer through the whole thing next time
she then also added also a huge fan of
tiny barbecue grills well so she tried
to get ahead of it and be like oh I knew
it I wasn't doing you correctly I just
couldn't withstand it um but I think
what people are missing about this whole
fiasco is the photo the photo of her
hand that's not a real hand
that is a doll's hand and she definitely
faced ended and it's like shiny and
smooth and purpose she is a doll and she
is shiny and show me the hand that is
not a real hand
where are the wrinkles in the knuckles
she has like a spray-tan hand and like I
don't know I feel like when you're
getting a tattoo like there should just
be certain fact checkers around you you
know yeah it seems like she's pretty
capricious like one Japanese person or
someone who's flown in Japanese or it's
just I confirm with your followers or
something like we do with a toaster even
if she wanted to add it is it the third
symbol no it's in the middle right so
she couldn't even out of the China - so
but she said that this area peels off
just like you know when um tamra sun-god
the touch is sort of temporary sort of
yes so if she wants it again
right next time and she really doesn't
seem to care oh so that's pretty
hilarious also it's not like this is her
one and only tattoo you and it's [ __ ]
up like she has tattoos everywhere she
covers them up all the time she had
pizza sitting on her finger she got
Pete's dad's thing on her foot
yeah she covered up her 8:41 eight
tattoo on her foot which had been a
tribute to Pete Davidson's late father
with a Mac Miller tribute after she and
the SNL star called off their engagement
this is my favorite part of the article
she also isn't the first celebrity to
make this kind of mistake
who else's ed Sheeran has a tattoo that
we that reads Galloway crew who does ed
Sheeran Gavin Japanese real instead of
Galway girl oh my god
um no why does it son go whatever it's
obviously not that good of a camera oh
this is so funny everyone just has all
these accidental girl tattoos like that
girl who got in Harry Styles face on her
thing
I heard it's a PR stunt and that it's
not real because it looked janky as hell
and it was red and oozing and it looks
like it was definitely infected with
some sort of disease I don't have any
tattoos and this is why right but no if
I did have a speller but if I were to
get one Roxie knee bags I think I would
get no regrets what would you get and
where would you get it I would get the
Hebrew word for family Misha Baha maybe
like know know where it could be seen
like they might be right in my chest you
know in huge letters like snow regards
yeah exactly what do I you I think I'll
get rocks tini bags which is Hebrew for
Sweeney Babs only steamy vibes only in
Hebrew and now it's about where cuz
everywhere has like some sort of you
know yeah
nowhere in the neck on it like nowhere
neck your face chest region
ya know where on the back so maybe
braids look right above your ass crack
no but like that's nothing angle oh so I
do kind of like the wrist but one that
seems painful and two it's like when you
get all dressed up or you could cover it
up by a watch or something sometimes
even if you're getting a tattoo and you
want to cover it up you shouldn't be
getting a tattoo right no wait I might
just be like for you maybe like here
like under your boob on the side oh I
have some friends who have tattoos that
you yeah I've got this really cool rock
shake will please cuz it's like bony and
that's cool yeah but like if if you
don't show off that part of your body
ever like me it's kind of you so then
it's like you're right
dress and somehow it you see it if it's
like a cutout dress or something like
that's not a good look
no because you don't want tattoos so
you're like the last person you should
be getting a tattoo because if you get a
tattoo you want to show it off and you
hope that the cutouts and your dress
show it off you should get one that says
Theo's mom
across in my far head done or on my
eyelid it's one Theo's mom or yeah
actually would do that the inner lip
goes away yeah sure okay next story I'm
obsessed with how kylie jenner's spent
ten thousand dollars in post mates in
2018 post meets is like giving out there
he used data I'm pretty sure this is a
partnership and I'm here for it because
we're getting major insight into kayo
that's tactically not a lot though
because post Malone got forty thousand
right Kylie Jenner is too busy growing
her billion-dollar beauty empire for
food runs so she often orders takeout oh
she also kept cooks a lot the reality TV
star a new mom 21 spent a jaw-dropping
ten thousand dollars in post mates
orders in 2018 according to the company
she usually orders about every other day
with her most common order being a cream
cheese bagel around 10 a.m. Wow he's
such a Jew she's such as a regular girl
like she eats bagels with cream cheese
me too that's my go-to order did you get
me like drinks or beverages or sides
Jenner who lives in LA near her famous
siblings also regularly regularly orders
miso ramen bowls chicken fried rice
matcha lattes and pasta but the Stars
most bizarre orders come from Boozer
most orders most bizarre orders most
bizarre orders from post mates were
quote three cozy blankets from Target
nail polish remover and one carrot quote
I was making matzo ball soup and had all
the ingredients but carrots but she's
not the only kardashian-jenner who used
his post meats to the max her older
brother Rob Aggie who was rarely seen
these days because he doesn't leave the
house stop he's on par with her ordering
skills oh my god quote Rob and I
probably post mates the same we post
mates each other things to try all the
time like new drinks and stuff
drinks sure remember that episode when
Kim was in that old house that like that
she lived in with Kris Humphries and Rob
was eating a burger and then he also
wanted to order Chinese and I was like
right when he started gaining weight and
they were like Robin you can't eat that
that way and like now doesn't even seem
like a big deal I was watching an old
episode where they're at dr. ourian's
and Rob is like he doesn't want to take
his shirt off he's like and he's crying
they keep the cameras out he's like it
was just so fat and like he wasn't even
fat at that point
oh well and that's what's so sad that's
the thing about like weight gain and
weight loss is gonna get a tattoo
removed I think maybe read over uh it's
so much of a mental thing cuz like I
look back on my time hop now and I'm
like I go through and I'm like oh my god
I was so beautiful and my skin was great
and I was in great shape and in my mind
back then I was a beast dude I mean yeah
it's so it's really all about how you
feel hence I feel pretty I look at my
time every day because I love I also
love seeing mostly pictures from a year
ago cuz this time last year I was like
steadily gaining like one pound a day I
didn't even realize and then every
picture from every day on time and I'm
later and bigger it's just my face like
we were this time I say like we were
interviewing like AnnaLynne McCord and
like I thought I was so cute but that's
just my face is getting rounder and
rounder and now I realized how I ended
up in June like being you know chunk
stir well I love looking at my time up
but it is depressing like I'd sometimes
I'll scroll and be like oh my god what
was I wearing or oh my god I never want
to hang out with this person again
delete delete and they have a new
feature you can hide stuff so it's like
if you're swiping through and you see a
photo that you never want to see ever
again you press hide from my die line
for my time up and it never comes back
you can't hide from yourself you can
hide your ex's little buddy hide its on
memories no I mean there are things like
if I never saw it on my time up I would
never remember again so why do I need to
see it on my time hop because thank you
sure memory came from know where you're
going I will be utilizing the hot the
hidden feature on time up all the time
and says she do so download time up and
check it out I actually really do like
looking at my time on I look at my time
at my time up streak right now is like
205 days in a row that I've looked at my
time hop oh my god I really look at it
everyday
mostly when I'm on the toilet sometimes
when I when I'm like on a good streak I
definitely miss a day but it says I
don't yeah they're generous like that
it's not it's not like stuff you know
like something like your heart comes
crumbling down yeah agreed
anyways it's nice to know made the 10
year challenge really easy hate to see
it hate to see it happen okay fifth and
final story before we recap siesta key
yes I did watch Christina Aguilera
announces Las Vegas residency in a
crystal mask Oh God everyone needs to
stop
nothing says diva like a fully bedazzled
faced Chris
Tina Aguilera announced wasicus
residency on Tuesday by instagramming
the show's promotional poster which
features her face completely covered in
crystals down to her lips and eyebrows
in behind-the-scenes Instagram video
from the shoot the 38 oral pop icon
poses in a towel an oversized leather
jacket with her tousled blond hair
falling across her bedazzled forehead
while Donna summers I feel love plays in
the background even think it should be a
Christina Aguilera song playing she
appeared on The Ellen DeGeneres Show to
reveal that she that now that she's
finished with her liberation tour she's
ready to do more shows she asked
DeGeneres should I say it before sharing
even though this whole interview was set
up just for to share this news it's been
in talks for a quite a few years now but
now that I've got my feet wet I'm going
to do a residency in Vegas the Christina
Aguilera the Christina Aguilera
Aguila Christina Aguilera who's Susan
Aguilera she sounds amazing it's just a
new album impersonator in Vegas if you
can't afford the show no it's like
Christina Aguilera oh I'm so sorry I'm
so sorry Christina Aguilera whatever I
just keep going I apologize 1000 times
I'm so sorry uh Christina Aguilera the
experience is set to open at Zappos
theatre at Planet Hollywood Resort and
Casino at the end of May
oh [ __ ] what's a blos theater oh please
make that Maison Ramsey sir but the
thing about residency's is like where do
we delineate I don't know if that's the
right word between residency and just
doing like three or four shows this is a
residency like a Britney Spears Celine
Dion yes Britney is out Christina is in
oh really he's done in Vegas she's like
Mario but like this is the slot opened
up and it's a perfect opportunity for
Christina because I feel as though she's
not you know retirement level but she's
not you know in her heyday touring
dancing etc be nice to her to settle
down in Vegas and she does the voice too
so she has like a lot of stability she's
okay but do you think she's gonna be
generating tons of ticket sales yes you
do yeah that's here I would see her too
but like we like weird that I would see
her before I would see Britney okay well
I just gotta see Celine that's all I'm
consider I have to see sleet I have much
to do um but it's really crazy how all
of these residency's term alert used
loosely and strongly are popping up in
Vegas now like Vegas you should just be
like a place for retirees right you know
get there to finish their career
retirement fund
yes you finally catch their social Donny
and Marie yeah Wayne Newton John no
that's not his name wait oh wait new
Olivia newton-john that's funny I [ __ ]
up either
I [ __ ] so hard with Wayne Newton you
did danke Schoen darling danke Schoen
thank you for all the joy and pain I
recall Central Parking fall how you did
you tear your dress yeah what a mess I
mean I confess that's not all it's such
a great song he doesn't still perform is
he still alive he is still alive and
kicking and kicking somewhere pad itself
um have you heard anything about the
Michael Jackson documentary um yes I
have I've heard it is brutal me too it
premiered at Sundance weird estimates
it's four hours it's gonna be an HBO
documentary the family obviously is up
in arms over it it's the story of two
now boys now men who at the time denied
the claims like when they when Michael
Jackson was on trial like they deny that
he abused them but now have come forward
and it is it's it's dark
well the estate of Michael Jackson which
I believe is like the voice of his
family and whatever says it's like so
terrible they called it a public
lynching and that it's wildly untrue
well obviously they're gonna say that
but obviously but I'll be seeing it me
too I'll so I'll be seeing the Bluebird
documentary but that's at South by not
at sundown I'm just really into
documentaries and the world is - I feel
like the trend of like true crime is
like they're now moving into documentary
form and then we've got a search for
crime broadcast like if we want to be
successful right if we won't have any
the morning crime oh wow that's a little
mornings a little early for crime okay
fine the midday crime okay done who are
we just saying oh not only am I here for
documentaries but it's like now I can't
even see movies that aren't based on
true stories like if you're making [ __ ]
up and gonna give me a bit about it I'm
not interested I only want pits about
things that have happened that deserve
pits a meta fellworthy
you tell up by the way I lost my dry
cleaning ticket though so let me pick it
up
I keep losing all my tickets people who
start giving electric tickets
one day also I went to the shoemaker
today lost my tickets for two different
orders I'm so irresponsible
I also saw another human being in my
lobby and it was the craziest thing I
got in the elevator and there was
someone in there like I screamed at the
top my lungs good I get scared easily
and I never see anyone in my building
cuz everyone hill is my building like I
believe this is like their second or
third home so I was like screamed at the
top my lungs to the sky I might oh I'm
so sorry
he was like that's okay I literally
never see anyone in the elevators he
scared me I'm like no I never see anyone
the elevators like to love year he was
like yeah he's that only part time like
that's what rich people say I'm like oh
yeah me too he said you live here
full-time it was like literally the most
embarrassing thing I was like yeah like
okay yeah I was like embarrassed he was
like yeah no nobody lives here full-time
to you and I was like yeah like I wasn't
like scared so where have you laid the
other part of the - I lied I said I do
live here full-time I mean sorry I told
the truth
oh good good that's yeah it'll be sadder
when you're so embarrassed that you like
lie about your life no I know but like I
was feeling embarrassed he like post he
didn't a question he was like and he
said the way he said it I never heard
about Gonzaga I only live in this
building part time I'm like oh okay and
he's like you live here full-time like
what this condescension his voice and I
was like peasant yeah and like you know
everyone like Owens and I'm like a
little renter it was just truly like an
embarrassing moment for me
I'm sorry pink you know you're younger
than them like you suck time to like you
know have a part time home yeah like
where were they when they were your age
right oh yeah ever in the building is
littering on the hospice please
Hospice is so sad yeah I've never seen
anyone on Hospice well hang out in your
Lobby
totally you'll find someone but like
when the Karen McCluskey was on Hospice
in desparate I was like I cried so hard
so you just know it's terrible it is but
you know that's life very sad my nails
are so scary by the way I'm gonna do
something crazy I'm gonna get gel on my
toes you know what rash I throw such a
good idea because like so it stays so
long oh my god why is it trash I don't
know it just gives me trashy vibes it's
like getting a French pedicure on your
show oh my god oh so not the same are
you kidding like you want my nice bright
shirt Oh
French on your toes is undeniably trashy
and disgusting
gel is just practical I don't know if I
ever see anyone sitting with that UV
machine on their feet I'm like well I've
never seen it that's why and I just
figured it would be such a good idea I
just feel like you should what why do
you need it to stay for two weeks you
know I was in Mexico kami Moroni had
like such nice feet and she said guys
you gel on my toes I just started doing
it my mom told me it's genius
and like oh my god that is genus she's
like I'd literally never get my toes
done I never get my toes done and I do
regular also unless you're going
swimming a lot which I don't have here
like she's in LA like yeah maybe it was
always charged here I was away for four
days pedicures literally last a week
unless you go swimming when they chip
like baked Lay's right but literally I
get my I got a pedicure like once a
month
I never go and look at a month that's so
much oh really I only go when I feel my
toes start to get really long and then
my shoes feel tight I think by the way
there's nothing there's no worse feeling
than like having long toenails that like
can create like caused damage to others
to your blankets gets caught in your
tights
that's another stretch your your your
lover something that I suffered from for
a really long time and I don't like this
isn't a thing that happens but it
happened to me because the customer
service at Modell's was so terrible that
I couldn't find them I couldn't find the
right pair of socks so I bought girls
socks apparently what four-cam chose oh
I was bouncing on child as his child
okay and they were they looked like I
could wear them and I wore them for
months and they were too small and every
time I wore them my toes really hurt
because it was they were too tight like
my toes were starting to like become
ingrown because it's a small shock
syndrome you know and then you make a
hole with you're not even the it was
like they were too tight
small shock syndrome you got it's like
it's really it's SSS it's a really big
like thing I don't know if any of you
have suffered from it I feel like some
people honestly you're too ashamed to
say them I wear size I wear and they
wore them for seems normal socks from
Amazon made for actually from Costco
Ben's mom every time she what's Costco
gets me bulk size socks because for some
reason like I wear them I've had them in
the laundry they go through the Machine
and they never come out ya know they
fall into the pipes it's where I think
no some one of the toasters gave me a
good advice a couple days ago to run my
dishwasher cuz I said my clothes I kind
of smell I think it's like my pipes to
run an empty load with white wine
vinegar and it totally [ __ ] work
my clothes smell amazing for a while
when I was doing my laundry when I got
actually now that makes sense my clothes
smelled and then I was told you are
supposed to leave the door to your
washing machine open so that I could
drive Billy yeah I was saying you can
leave it closed when you're not using it
yeah like it's wet stuff yeah but like
to drive space you have you're just
leaving all these doors open ugly look
but I started doing that and it helped
and then I just also started using for
detergent but you don't have to use it
for the dryer no cuz the dryer isn't can
you meet my Mike for a second I'm about
to coffin and ain't gonna be pretty
11:11 make a wish justice for the girls
justice for Jesse smell it justice for
the girls justice for Jesse smell I wish
my cop would go I wish my cough will go
away I wish my cough will go a witch my
cough would go away streaming platform
streaming platform streaming platform
streaming platform and honestly
Louboutin scarf Louboutin scarf at
Louboutin scars I drew a picture see
that on the horizon for you
yeah I cuz I'm gonna buy it for myself
what do I want materially that's why
this started because you need to ask for
like material things that you can
quantify it's also nice to have goals
like to set financial goals for yourself
like so you save you make money you work
hard and then in a couple months time
you can get that five hundred dollar
scarf honestly it's just like too much
money to spend on a scarf it's so stupid
and wear scarves literally never maybe
that's because I don't have a Louis
Vuitton one and honestly Heather Mooney
and I need to fold scarves I agree I
feel like Heather Mooney is another type
of person like a Lilly Moscovitz where
we would go back in time
watch Romy Michele and agree with her
completely like a reunion is stupid
we're even a stupid and cigarettes to
burn to sell and Sandi Frank she was a
weirdo she would have [ __ ] with a
jewels so hard oh my god honestly
totally true
Heather Mooney grew up in the wrong time
period yeah if she had went to high
school with jewel season but actually
she wouldn't been rich cuz she would
have had time to admit the quick brain
paper no but she might have been meant
to the jewel that doesn't give you strap
okay so either way I meant to tell you
this cuz you had what I this week Sunday
Saturday and Friday night I was drooling
like a middle schooler and I and I'm
paying the price I had a sore throat and
that has now evolved into a full-blown
cold like I'm coughing and sneezing so
do you think it was jewel related I was
just sick old soul induced did you get a
cold I felt like [ __ ] and maybe that's
him so the elements now know I'm I don't
remember I lost my voice like almost
completely remember when I didn't have a
voice yeah so that was from your stinky
shoes yes
was a jewel Genesis a jewel emesis yeah
crazy these aren't the side effects that
they tell you about like really if you
want to stop people actually that's
still one I want to talk about sticky
because it's just the best show on
television and every time I hear that
carly rae jepsen song come on i get like
so in the mood for the show you don't
even like he has to have blond hair I
put me in a bikini take me to Florida
like I just like pure bar yeah oh my god
when she Olli had said like her dream
was to own appear bar like let's and
Alex took a hot steaming dump on her
dreams
Alex is evil okay we'll get into it he
is he's evil but let's start from the
beginning what happened um Brandon's in
the studio and when I was watching and I
was like a'ight I was controversial
about this and I don't want to like I
just see something controversial that
girls voice Alana it's terrible well it
sounded good you know with everything
but when they worse went down on them
and there was just the two of them
singing for one second and they're
singing at the piano at his house when
his girlfriend facetimes like her voice
is so bad yeah her voice is pretty bad
but she's beautiful she was the best
dressed at the 70s party and for that I
think her yeah his girlfriend gives me
like Raquel vibes like from Raquel
Alevis but it's like she's a groupie she
doesn't it's like you don't have even
ground to stand on like I forgot that he
had a girlfriend until the episode
started I didn't know that he did and
everything she looked different
she told and then when she was say
signing him with her tits she was great
so Cara and Garrett went on a date here
for it Australia I've been Singapore oh
yeah I went last summer she's honestly
so obnoxious and every time she talks
about Alex I want to die I mean like
it's just so crazy how it's want to be
so bad really I don't see that at all
but then when she was at sake when she's
with Chloe talking about Alex I can't
stand her but that's why she's on the
show so she's giving it right when she
was at the aquarium with Jared like they
were being cute they had a decent
conversation and then when he was
wishing for all those things and she was
just like I I had all those thing it was
really awkward like jet jet ski a house
in California land another date with her
like literally she could give him all
those things right then and there and so
we said this last week but like the
whole new element of money it's like
making me so uncomfortable like when she
was recapping her date with canvas and
Chloe and she was like I mean like does
he know you have money like if it's like
does he know you have cancer like it's
like the great they talk about it like
they're along to know it's just like I
really don't like how they all are
talking about money but like when I wait
she's a night when they were all sitting
around
about her like and how awful she is she
was like instant she tweeted this
insecure jealous gold digger and
immature are we missing one and she
replied okay
poor no like this new element of money
is really weird and I don't like it like
it makes me uncomfortable because like
when she was like Alex just rolled up in
a car that cost more than my parents
house my news third car terrible now
that's the same as terrible and honestly
Alex's dad is a monster he is but he's
actually he doesn't seem like a bad guy
it's like he's he has the wrong son like
someone else would be like who's going
to law school and I was kind of doing
all very things like he's in school he's
gonna be a lawyer
hope you get past the bar start his own
practice and that would be great like
he'll have a law firm and his dad should
give him that if he can but alex is just
so undeserving because he's just a
colossal piece of [ __ ] Roy doesn't
appreciate Julie and the fine woman that
she has English oh and the only reason I
don't like his dad is because he's like
encouraging Alex like be single and
break up with Juliet when Julie that's
the best thing that ever happened to
Alex mind you something that like I feel
a real shift in it's like when this show
started and it was really Alex's dad
filming the show about like Alex's House
announces parties and Alex's life Alex
was like a major douche major but then
between that filming the show premiered
all before the show and premiere there's
backlash against Alex the whole world
hated and still takes Alex like shark
dragging me up here in the fish's mouth
everything so he's been through like a
full like public shaming shaming shame
and Juliet is like the belle of siesta
key and like she really has stuck by him
like I think his ego took a major
bruising also it's been like three years
since the first episode so he people do
grow up and it's actually very humbling
to have the whole world it's been a year
and a half and by the way a year and a
half also when Chloe told Alex that she
was in love with him oh so hope at the
beginning of last season Chloe was in
love with Alex and sabotaging Juliet
because she was in love without say
people aren't piecing that together and
when Kara was like what it's been like
two years like saying like it should be
more than that and close like yeah
you're here in two years ya know but
you're not I'm like that's it a year and
a half they were the cast of siesta key
already and she was being a [ __ ] to
Juliet so it was because she was in love
with Alex and those feel
no offense Chloe it love you still run
deep because everything she's doing is
to get under Julie but in this moment in
time on the show is she in a
relationship yes but they're just not
talking about it yes
because if like he can't film that's no
fun because I should say no I'm not in
love without I have a boyfriend right
it's just like inconclusive right but I
was saying this Alex was a major major
douche last season this season he's just
regular style douche there's some things
that he does that I actually kind of
agree with it I agree with him I Julia
needs to be like less and secure and
less jealous but then when he's like
calling her an idiot and I'm asked I
want to kick him and talk about all the
things he does for her like you got her
Starbucks like wow he felt up her car it
was nice but it's kind of I think that
like if we lived in the suburbs or we
had cars like that's just a thing like
husband's do that their wives like I
don't think it's like to me it's like
you're gonna go to New Jersey you get
gas that's amazing also Juliet's driving
every weekend to see him like that cost
gas money and yes you are the more rich
one and you're just the man chivalry
ain't dead [ __ ] no and she's young like
she's still in college shows I'm
adjusting your money I literally was
hating him so hard what just named you
me Bessie Oh bless you I'm sorry so I
just like I want to break his jaw again
sometimes but I also like Julia it
really does love him and I do think that
like he is sweet to her sometimes but
when Polly Polly is the dev Oh like we
need to laugh yeah that's right it's
like you think I mooch off of Alex I'm
ass [ __ ] girlfriend he's supposed to
like be chivalrous and take me to dinner
you are a low-life who calls him his
cousin you're not even [ __ ] related
but you live in his house and make his
dad jail you bail you out of prison like
you are a [ __ ] mooch lowlife Plaza
we need to lack Polly up and throw away
the key yeah swell I want to start to
change our org petition to get him off
the show I'm so done thing anyone but
I'm it cuz like not that many people
watch a show yet yeah did you ever God I
shipped so many things about Kelsey I
ship her defending Juliet on Twitter do
Drita yes I ship her and Jared I meet
him her boyfriends gotta go I just ship
anyone who's giving Jared the respect
that he deserves
and honestly Alex could have done a lot
worse than that conversation and for
that I was glad it was over like they
keep disrespecting him and I don't like
it so I just wanted that to end and
glad that it and so in situations like
that like Alex was a normal decent
person even though like they were like
we both did something wrong really I
don't think Jared did anything wrong
right what it was painful but we got to
decent conclusion Alex is growing but
the fact that he doesn't appreciate
Juliette for the perfect angel that she
is is deeply upsetting
that's probably they go too much so for
that face and like I'm TD the face is
beautiful in person the face has a
radiant the smallest most perfect how do
you look at that face and disrespect it
and call it an idiot that bar that they
went to which also is where Kelsey and
Alex went on their date last year looks
so fun with the square-dancing also I
love Kelsey she's just a great reality
TV character because like she has a
boyfriend and that means nothing to her
yeah and that's what it's supposed to be
him on a show when they were like
dancing and he was picking her up and
it's like highly inappropriate I was
just like I just I don't wanna watch oh
no I can't that's boring but also
Madison's like lover telling that girl
that like he's kind of single that was
really weird he is I mean he came to
siesta key he lives in Texas or wherever
he came for her for the weekend so weird
it's so weird he's so cute he is cute
but I don't like his bag like I don't I
just want someone who's like like and
that's what I like about Garrett like
he's just like thirsting for a
relationship at all times and like it's
really sweet like all these guys like
want to hook up with these girls not be
in a relationship in a relationship like
you guys are such [ __ ] losers when
will you get that through your head so
obviously Brandon and that girl are
gonna hook up and like it's gonna be JA
but like I so don't care like I liked
him and Madison but I can't care about
his relationship I don't like so
uninteresting I don't like him in
Madison anymore because they're not like
they're both I actually like both of
them separately and they're not right
for each other like she's just like by
the way wise canvas riding Juliet's dick
so hard like every time someone's
talking [ __ ] about Juliet canvas is
right there because she still hasn't
been confirmed full time cast member and
whatever it's gonna take yeah well it
was a good episode I just love the
season like I love I'm just so glad it's
back same and I'm glad that Juliet and
Chloe are on good terms right now and
that they're both going ahead and I
actually and Juliet was saying like yes
I do you think Chloe apologize because
she wants to go to Miami but I do think
a big part of her was actually sincere
you can always tell when someone's fake
apologizing and she did make it seem
like she was only apologizing and the
time wasn't good because like she wanted
to go to Miami but I do think she was
sincere and I think she was tired of
fighting
with her friends and have another one
like her they all to live tweet the
episodes in like the most dramatic shady
way like they do a good job of like
marketing the show I have to sneeze
again
bless you
they do hey great yeah yes they do a
great job of live tweeting it oh and
Chloe didn't bring Kara to the Buffalo
saloon who did no one that she wasn't
there
right so I thought that that was like
you know if she was trying to be a stuff
starter and go to Miami she would a bar
Karen apologized but she didn't ring
Kara's she's trying to do straight
towards him she got called out like all
the things you've been doing for the
past years cuz like you had a crush on
Alex and that's fine but just like own
it and move on yeah and just like except
Alison Juliette and you know if everyone
stopped pushing Juliet's buttons maybe
she would stop acting so jealous and
insecure and outs like would be nice to
her maybe also like I mean do you do you
want really have to break up with Alex
yeah you do yeah who we'd rather see her
with yeah Jared no honestly Carlton
Moises Naim from last season with the
save hold him no no he likes cows Korver
yeah I'm like really like white name and
he's friends with Brandon Cup Carrie
Corvin Connor no its mother and this is
no it's not no it's not I'm gonna look
it up
Corie Corie no Kalamazoo Carson Carson
Thank You Stephanie Gabrielle Benitez
oh no sorry Carly McManus Carson thank
you guys
Carson and Juliet are like the perfect
couple
he's just Carson's a [ __ ] no we haven't
gotten to know him no we have like and
you know what it doesn't seem like
there's anything worth getting show we
we met Jarrod for five minutes and we're
interested the arson had a whole season
of being like a second to your cast
member and he got bumped down to third
tier he didn't even stay at second tier
yeah no he was like canvas last year and
canvas worked her way up the ladder and
Carson just fell flat right like he got
the opportunity and he didn't make it I
don't think it would make for great TV
if Alex and Juliet broke up but I'm not
really in the mood to like I just want
them to be good because I don't want to
talk about them like it's not that thing
and I do like I tried like I love Julia
and they trust her and so she really
loves Alex and there's something in them
in their relationship that we don't see
and it if that's what she wants they
want her to be happy but when he's like
stepping on her dreams of owning a pier
bar which isn't that far-fetched
considering like she's the best
advertisement for pure bar I've ever
seen
yeah um then you're being an [ __ ] I
couldn't agree more and just that whole
conversation where I guess like she
ordered a pizza on his tab is that what
started it I don't know and then she was
like your parents rich as [ __ ] it's fine
he was you know what she's been she said
something he said something and she was
like and I'm ordering a pizza it's
unclear what exactly happened to start
the fight but Alex was so mean and so
wrong that it doesn't matter right like
if you just got your third Bentley like
got a [ __ ] pizza for your girlfriend
who's so thin and she needs it she's
withering away I know you should feed
her because you're a big oaf totally I
really can't stand him I can't stand
like I think that if Paulie like
mysteriously disappeared because two
girls went and captured him and walked
him up and threw away the key
two girls who are sisters and host a
morning show and they're both beautiful
and skinny and really smart then I think
Alex and Juliet could stand a chance
yeah Paul and Alex for like a grown man
is so easily influenced by his like
loser cousin degenerate who gets
arrested like please yeah man Alex I
can't stand Polly
okay well that's all we got any other
shows we want to recap no no he's not
tonight
I'm so excited i watch half of Lohan
Beach Club nothing to discuss about the
last five minutes before siesta key
who slapped the other the girl who
slapped was completely wrong is she
gonna get fired for slapping he knows it
doesn't look like that Hey look I know
yeah and like it was really sad and then
all the girls were like sitting with the
slapper and laughing about the other
girl who had just got inside and then
she was alone that's sad and the reason
why she slapped her is because I guess
this girl was interested in some guy and
they were all walking past him at the
club and the girl like kissing my most
cheeks and said hi like and she was like
you were being so extra she was like I
gave me because I said hello he said
these people will just really want a
second season and then we're gonna hard
for it oh yeah they're like the
warehouses of Delos they worked hard for
that second and third season right they
never have a guaranteed season and so
they always gave it their own no and I'm
down for everyone working hard for it as
long as like the right calls are being
made a justice is being served like the
slapper and the sloppy don't get treated
the same just great we're in the slap Oh
buddy the slapper needs harsher
punishment and the sloppy yeah um Robin
drama why were you but like you were the
slapper you're the sake like how's your
face yeah well that's all he got
tomorrow's episode will be podcast only
so make sure to look out for that we'll
put it up in the morning at noon so in
about 30 minutes I am releasing presale
tickets on patreon for two of my
California shows in Irvine and Brea my
second Houston show tickets are going on
sale at my second Greenville South
Carolina show tickets are going on sale
if you're not a pH I remember you might
miss out if any of them sell out so
maybe just become one in the next 30
minutes and then cancel it that's all I
got for you
I think suite call me a cracker I'll
move out
yeah okay yeah do it follow me I tracked
you no problems and pup with no job he
is so [ __ ] premium and he's gonna
make a million dollars next year you
mark my words I really look forward to
that because I get like half thank you
guys so much for being again 10% we love
you and we will see you to actually
Jackie we'll see you Friday I'll see you
Tuesday
oh yeah bye
you